SPEAR.
IT IS THE BIGGEST NATIONAL
SCANDAL BY FAR IN OUR
LIFETIME.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE
INFORMATION, CONGRESSMAN JIM
JORDAN AND MATT GAETZ AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR SARA
CARTER.
LET ME ASK ALL THREE OF YOU,
YES OR NO, AM I OVER THE
TARGET?
JIM JORDAN?
>> SEAN, WHAT I READ TODAY
IN THAT CLASSIFIED BRIEFING
ROOM IS AS BAD AS I THOUGHT
IT WAS.
AND EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
CITIZEN SHOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SEE THAT
INFORMATION TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT OUR FBI WAS UP TO.
>> Sean: WILL IT SHOCK THE
CONSCIENCE OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> SEAN IT, SHOCKED ME.
I COMPARED IT TO -- I
REMEMBER THE DAY I WALKED IN
TWO YEARS AGO ON THE
BENGHAZI COMMITTEE WALKED IN
AND SOUGHT IMMUNITY
AGREEMENTS GIVEN TO PEOPLE
IN THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
I DIDN’T KNOW WHO THEY HAD
GIVEN THEM TO.
I OPENED UP THAT FOLDER AND
I LOOKED DOWN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL SLID
THAT FOLDER OVER TO ME ON
THE TABLE AND LOOK DOWN AND
SAY THEY GAVE CHERYL MILLS
IMMUNITY DURING THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION?
CLINTON’S CHIEF OF STAFF?
HER LAWYER, TODAY WHEN I
READ THE MATERIAL, I HAD
THAT SAME SHOCKED FEELING I
WAS LIKE WAIT A MINUTE, THIS
ACTUALLY HAPPENED FROM OUR
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THIS
FBI?
THAT’S HOW SERIOUS THIS IS
THAT’S WHY WE ARE CALLING ON
EVERY BIT OF THAT
INFORMATION WE GOT TO SEE
TODAY TO BE MADE PUBLIC FOR
YOU TO SEE, FOR JOURNALISTS
TO THE SEE, MOST IMPORTANTLY
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
SEE.
>> Sean: MATT GAETZ YOU SAW
THESE MATERIALS TODAY YOU
ARE AGREEING WITH JIM
JORDAN.
IT SOUNDED LIKE A FEW PEOPLE
DECIDED THEY WANTED TO FIX,
THEY FIXED IT NOT ONLY SO
HILLARY WOULD GET IN TROUBLE
ON THE EMAIL SERVER SCANDAL
WE KNOW FELONIES WERE.
SHE RIGID THE PRIMARY.
SOUNDS LIKE THEY ARE FIXING
AND RIGGING HERE A GENERAL
ELECTION OR TO OVERTURN AN
ELECTION AND, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, WHATEVER WORD YOU WANT
TO DESCRIBE THAT.
FIXING, RIGGING, A COUP, I
DON’T KNOW.
>> YOU ARE DESCRIBING THE
VERY ELEMENTS OF A PALACE
COUP, AND AFTER MEADOWS AND
OTHERS OF US REVIEWS
INTELLIGENCE INFORMATION
TODAY IT’S ABUNDANTLY CLEAR
THAT THE ENTIRE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION IS A LIABILITY
ON A FOUNDATION OF
CORRUPTION.
AND WHAT IS SO IMPORTANT IS
THAT WE GET THIS INFORMATION
IN TO THE PUBLIC SQUARE.
THE BEST DISINFECTANT FOR
THIS CORRUPTION IS GOING TO
BE SUNSHINE AND THAT’S WHY
JIM JORDAN AND I HAVE JOINED
MANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS IN CALLING FOR THIS
INFORMATION TO BE RELEASED
FOR THE REVIEW OF ALL OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, SEAN, WHEN YOU
BEEN ON THIS SHOW EACH AND
EVERY NIGHT MAKING CLAIMS
ABOUT THE BIAS AND THE
CORRUPTION AND THE DEEP
STATE, PEOPLE HAVE ACCUSED
YOU AND YOUR GUESTS OF BEING
TIN FOIL HAT FOLKS, LONE
VOICES IN THE WILDERNESS.
THIS CRITICAL INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION WILL CONVINCED
INDICATE THE CLAIMS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE BY SO MANY
AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT WE SHARE IT
WITH ALL AMERICANS.
THAT’S WHAT WE’RE FIGHTING
FOR IN THE CONGRESS.
>> Sean: IT S. IT A FAIR
STATEMENT THAT ONION WE HAVE
BEEN UNPEELING WE HAVE BEEN
OVER THE TARGET THE WHOLE
TIME, CONGRESSMAN GATES?
>> WELL, SEAN, WE CAN’T GET
INTO THE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION, BUT I CAN TELL
YOU I’M AS CERTAIN AS EVER
THAT THE CLAIMS WE HAVE BEEN
MAKING ARE ACCURATE CLAIMS
THAT THERE IS INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION THAT BACKS IT
UP.
AND THAT THERE HAS BEEN A
REAL ATTEMPT TO UNDERMINE
THIS PRESIDENT AND IT HAS
COME FROM THE SCARIEST OF
PLACES.
SOME OF THE VERY PEOPLE WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT WILL
BE EXPOSED AND THE KEY
REASON THAT ALL AMERICANS
NEED TO SEE THIS MEMO IS
THAT IT NAMES NAMES.
IT SAYS WHO WAS INVOLVED
WITH WHO.
HOW DIFFERENT ACTORS AND
CHARACTERS WE HAVE HEARD
ABOUT INTERACTED WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
AND THAT IS THE TYPE OF
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED ALL
AMERICANS TO SEE
IMMEDIATELY.
>> Sean: SARA CARTER YOU
HAVE BEEN ALL OVER THIS ALL
DAY.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
YOUR REPORTING?
>> WELL, I CAN CERTAINLY SAY
THAT MY REPORTING COINCIDES
WITH WHAT CONGRESSMAN GATES
AND CONGRESSMAN JORDAN ARE
SAYING.
AND I THINK IT’S FAR WORSE
THAN WHAT I BELIEVED COULD
HAVE HAPPENED.
FROM WHAT I HAVE BEEN TOLD,
SENIOR GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
MAY BE REMOVED FROM OFFICE,
MAY BE FIRED.
I DON’T KNOW HOW FAR THIS
WILL GO.
I ALSO WANT A LOT OF THOSE
QUESTIONS ANSWERED, SEAN,
WHO WAS IN RELATIONSHIP TO
WHO WHEN IT CAME TO THESE
FISA WARRANTS?
HOW DID THEY OPERATE WITH
ONE ANOTHER?
WHAT WERE THESE REALLY
EGREGIOUS ACTIONS THAT TOOK
PLACE THAT ONLY THIS
MEMORANDUM AND REPORT CAN
TELL US?
AND I HAVE BEEN WATCHING MY
TWITTER FEED AND I HAVE BEEN
WATCHING TWITTER ALL DAY.
I’M SEEING #RELEASE THE
DOCUMENTS.
#RELEASE THE DOCUMENTS
EVERYWHERE.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC DESERVES
TO KNOW THE TRUTH HERE.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AND THIS WAS A
DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND IF PEOPLE WITHIN OUR OWN
GOVERNMENT WERE TRYING TO
USURP THAT AND CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY THEN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW.
>> Sean: I AGREE WITH YOU ON
RELEASE OF DOCUMENTS.
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
TONIGHT IN AN EDITORIAL,
THEY ARE DEMANDING THE SAME
THING.
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, WE
DESERVE TO SEE THIS.
YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
AND HOW SOON WILL WOULD HE
BE ABLE TO GET OUR EYES ON
THESE DOCUMENTS?
>> GREAT QUESTION, SEAN.
HERE IS THE PROCESS,
CHAIRMAN NUNES IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IN
THE HOUSE CAN HE BRING THE
COMMITTEE BACK TOGETHER.
THEY CAN HAVE A VOTE.
IF THE MAJORITY OF THE
COMMITTEE VOTES TO RELEASE
THESE DOCUMENTS, THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH GETS A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME TO
REVIEW THEM.
IF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
GIVES A THUMBS UP THEY GO
PUBLIC.
THIS COULD HAPPEN REAL
QUICK.
CHAIRMAN NUNES IS COMMITTED
TO GETTING THIS INFORMATION.
>> Sean: NOT ONE DEMOCRAT
WANTED YOU TO SEE IT.
>> NO THEY DIDN’T.
AFTER YOU READ IT AND
PLAYING PARTISAN POLITICS
YOU CAN SEE WHY THEY DIDN’T
WANT US TO SEE THAT AND WHY
THOUGH WON’T WANT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE U THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO
BE -- THIS SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN IN A COUNTRY AS GREAT
AS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND WE NEED EVERY
SINGLE AMERICAN, TAKE A LOOK
AT THIS AND SEE WHAT EXACTLY
THEIR GOVERNMENT DID AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION DID.
THIS IS THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION AND NEEDS TO BE
PUBLIC AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> Sean: SOUNDS TO ME LIKE A
LOT OF PEOPLE, CONGRESSMAN
GATES, NEED TO BE FIRED AND
INVESTIGATED.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
I THINK THAT THIS WILL NOT
END JUST WITH FIRINGS.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO WILL GO TO JAIL.
I WAS VERY PERSUADED BY THE
EVIDENCE.
AND IT ALSO BECAME CLEAR TO
ME WHY CHUCK GRASSLEY AND
LINDSEY GRAHAM FELT IT SO
IMPORTANT TO REFER THIS
MATTER FOR CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
YOU DON’T GET TO TRY TO
UNDERMINE OUR COUNTRY,
UNDERMINE OUR ELECTIONS AND
SIMPLY GET FIRED.
I THINK THERE WILL BE
CRIMINAL IMPLICATIONS HERE.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSCORE THE
POINT YOU JUST MADE.
EVERY SINGLE DEMOCRAT ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE VOTED
AGAINST EVEN ALLOWING OTHER
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO SEE
THIS INFORMATION.
SO YOU KNOW THEY’RE GOING TO
FIGHT AGAINST RELEASE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS SO
AFRAID OF?
WHY DON’T THEY WANT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE TO KNOW THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT WAS GOING
ON WITH THE GOVERNMENT, HOW
THAT IMPACTED THE PRESIDENT,
HIS TRANSITION, HIS CAMPAIGN
AND IT JUST SEEMS
INTERESTING TO ME THAT
DEMOCRATS DON’T WANT US TO
KNOW WHAT THE ENTIRE BASIS
WAS IN THE FIRST PLACE FOR
THE MUELLER PROBE THEY WANT
TO DRAG THIS OUT THROUGH THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS TO
EMBARRASS THIS PRESIDENT AND
DISTRACT FROM THE CRITICAL
WORK WE HAVE TO DO TO SAVE
THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
>> Sean: DO YOU CONCLUDE
THAT MUELLER, THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION SHOULD HAVE NEVER
COME UP.
DOES MUELLER NEED TO DISAND.
>> THIS WAS A LIABILITY ON
CORRUPTION BUILT ON A SHAM.
THE ENTIRE INVESTIGATION IS
A FICTION.
IT’S A FALLACY.
AND WHEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SEE HOW THIS BEGAN WHEN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE HOW
DIFFERENT PEOPLE I RECOLLECT
ACTORRED WITH ONE ANOTHER
AND HOW DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS WERE
INFILTRATED AND SUBJECTED TO
BIASED INDIVIDUALS AND HOW
THAT REALLY PLAYED OUT, I
THINK THAT EVERY AMERICAN
WILL UNDERSTAND HOW
ABSOLUTELY LUDICROUS IT IS
THAT WE CONTINUE TO ALLOW
THE MUELLER PROBE TO GO
FORWARD.
IT NEEDS TO END BECAUSE THE
ENTIRE BASIS IS A LIE.
>> Sean: I KNOW FROM MY
SOURCES, SARAH, THAT THEY
ARE SAYING THIS SHOULD
RESULT IN THE IMMEDIATE
FIRING OF LISA PAGE, OF
PETER STRZOK, OF BRUCE OHR,
ALSO ANDREW MCCABE.
I HAVE SOME QUESTIONS, WHERE
DOES ROD ROSENSTEIN STICK IN
THIS EQUATION THE ONE WHO
APPOINTED THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL?
BECAUSE WE NOW KNOW THE
DOSSIER, THE PHONY CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR DOSSIER
THAT WAS USED FOR THE FISA
WARRANT.
ALL OF THIS LEADS TO
MUELLER.
THAT NEVER SHOULD HAVE
HAPPENED BECAUSE IT WAS ON
OPPOSITION PARTY PROPAGANDA.
AND THEN WHAT’S WITH COMEY,
WHAT’S HIS INVOLVEMENT HERE?
WHERE DOES HE STAND?
WHERE DOES MUELLER’S
INVESTIGATION STAND BASED ON
YOUR REPORTING TONIGHT?
>> WELL, APPARENTLY, WHEN
THIS DOCUMENT GOES PUBLIC,
WHICH I BELIEVE IT WILL I DO
BELIEVE IT WILL BE THE
UNRAVELING OF THE MUELLER
PROBE.
AND I HAVE BEEN HEARING THAT
FROM OTHER SOURCES.
AND, SEAN, THIS WAS ALL
ABOUT IN THE BEGINNING,
REMEMBER, TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION, TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
NOW WE KNOW FROM WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM THE
SOURCES, FROM THE
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS WHO
HAVE SEEN THIS MEMO THAT THE
COLLUSION APPEARS TO BE
BETWEEN CERTAIN MEMBERS OF
THE FBI AND THE DOJ AND THE
MOSTLY CLOUDY CAMPAIGN AND
THAT THE FOUNDATION OF THIS
WAS ALL BASED ON LIES.
NOT ONLY DO I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT ROSENSTEIN WHO WAS
ACTUALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WAS WITHHOLDING THAT
INFORMATION FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME, YOU KNOW,
AND THEN FINALLY GAVE IT UP
TO THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
>> Sean: DID ROSENSTEIN SIGN
OFF ON EXTENSION OF THIS
WARRANT DO WE KNOW.
>> I DON’T KNOW THAT YET.
I HAVEN’T HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF SEEING THE ACTUAL
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT, OF
COURSE, THE CONGRESSIONAL
MEMBERS HAVE.
BUT I DO NOT KNOW THE ANSWER
TO THAT YET.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW HOW
SYDNEY BLUMENTHAL PLAYS INTO
ALL OF THIS BECAUSE I THINK
THAT’S GOING TO BE A VERY
TELLING REVELATION WHEN ALL
OF THIS COMES OUT.
>> Sean: DO YOU HAVE -- CAN
YOU GIVE US ANY INFORMATION,
NOT GIVING US ANY DETAILS,
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN ABOUT
COMEY, ABOUT MULLEN?
AND I’M VERY INTERESTED
ABOUT ROD ROSENSTEIN IN ALL
OF.
THIS NO.
THERE ARE CERTAIN PEOPLE WHO
CAN SIGN FISA APPLICATION.
ONLY CERTAIN PEOPLE CAN AT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
WE DON’T KNOW WHO DID.
AFTER DID YOU GO READ THIS
MATERIAL.
>> Sean: WOE, WE CAN
ELIMINATE THIS QUICKLY IT
WASN’T JEFF SESSIONS TO HO
WAS RECUSED.
EITHER ROSENSTEIN OR I
BELIEVE ONE OTHER PERSON HAS
THE ABILITY.
>> ONLY A HANDFUL OF PEOPLE
AT FBI AND JUSTICE WHO CAN
SIGN OFF ON ONE.
WHO DID THAT?
WE DON’T KNOW.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS WHAT WE
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT,
THIS SHOULD GO PUBLIC.
WE ALSO KNOW THERE IS MORE
TO COME.
THE INVESTIGATION AT THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS
NOT COMPLETE.
THANK GOODNESS THEY ARE
DOING WHAT THEY’RE DOING.
PUSH TO GET THESE DOCUMENTS
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THEIR INVESTIGATION IS NOT
COMPLETE.
WHEN IT’S COMPLETE, THEN YOU
ARE GOING TO SEE THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THE
HOUSE DO EVEN MORE.
>> Sean: COMEY HAD TO KNOW
ALL OF THIS WAS GOING ON,
DIDN’T HE?
>> WELL, AGAIN, WE CAN’T
TALK ABOUT SPECIFICS WHO
KNEW WHAT AND WHAT WE READ
TODAY.
WHAT WE READ TODAY THOUGH
WAS A MEMO THAT COMPILED
INFORMATION THAT THEY GOT
THAT THEY PRESENTED TO
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS TO LOOK
AT.
WE CALLED FOR MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS TO SEE THIS A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
NOW WE ARE CALLING ON ALL
AMERICANS TO BE ABLE TO SEE
THIS MATERIAL SO THEY CAN
SEE WHAT REALLY TOOK PLACE.
>> Sean: #RELEASE THE
DOCUMENT.